mike richards is stepping down as the
host of jeopardy after receiving
backlash for sexist comments he made in
the past and for taking on the hosting
gig when he was already the executive
producer of the show and
now the executive producer of jeopardy
mike richards
great johnny gilbert thank you very much
sir welcome everyone richards who was
announced as a new permanent host
earlier this month made the announcement
that he would no longer host the show in
an internal note to staff on friday he
also revealed that production would be
cancelled for the day in the message
richard said it pains him that the past
incidents and comments have cast such a
shadow on jeopardy adding that he was
deeply honored to be asked to host the
syndicated show and was thrilled by the
opportunity to expand his role it's very
important to keep it going but the 46
year old tv exec said over the last
several days it became clear that moving
forward as host would be too much of a
distraction for the fans and not the
right move for the show richards adds
that he is stepping down as host
effective immediately and as the search
for a new host begins guest hosts will
be brought on in the interim he
concluded his note writing quote i want
to apologize to each of you for the
unwanted negative attention that has
come to jeopardy over the last few weeks
and for the confusion and delays this is
now causing i know i have a lot of work
to do to regain your trust and
confidence we're trying to build a
kinder gentler society a spokesperson
for sony pictures television which
produces jeopardy also released a
statement to e.t saying they support
richard's decision to step down as the
host adding quote we were surprised this
week to learn of mike's
2013-2014 podcast and the offensive
language he used in the past we have
spoken with him about our concerns and
our expectations moving forward mike has
been with us for the last two years and
has led the jeopardy team through the
most challenging time the show has ever
experienced following alex trebek's
death it is our hope that as ep he will
continue to do so with professionalism
and respect the news comes one day after
richards issued a statement saying he
was deeply sorry for past controversial
comments he made that were resurfaced by
the ringer the outlet reported that
during his podcasts that he started in
2013 called the random show richards
made multiple questionable comments
about women's bodies in his statement on
thursday richards said quote it is
humbling to confront a terribly
embarrassing moment of misjudgment
thoughtlessness and insensitivity from
nearly a decade ago looking back now
there is no excuse of course for the
comments i made on this podcast and i am
deeply sorry
he never mentioned names to us
he
really
wanted to be the host of the show while
he was the host of the show it was his
show until he told us he was gonna
retire and and amazingly he never did
and i think that's a blessing eti was
with richards following the death of
longtime host alex trebek who died in
november following his battle with
pancreatic cancer and he opened up about
the qualities he'd like to see in a
future host he did talk about what it
would take to be a good jeopardy host
typical alex he was
self-deprecating said it's not that hard
let me tell you that is maybe the
hardest show on television to host
61 clues in 22 minutes
accents pronunciations
scoring
calling on people
ruling on the answers so he he he talked
a lot about that it needs to be someone
that
the audience will respect that's
believable in the role has credibility
um
and and that's
and that's who he was and he was so
smart that you you bought it
because
you knew he knew the answer to
you